. Hallo Hannover! Hey, da seid ihr! Hallo! Hi! Hannover! Was geht? Leute, das ist ja aufpassbar. Och Mensch, nee, ach Mensch, ihr seid doch sehr verrückt. Dankeschön, herzlich willkommen in Hannover. Hier sind aber viele. Es ist mir eine riesengroße Ehre, euch einen Mann vorstellen zu dürfen, den ihr so lange nicht vergessen werdet. Er ist heute hier, es ist Stafford Tietze! Er ist da! Und wer hätte es gedacht, dass er es heute hier einrichten kann, am 17. am Ausweichtermin, Florentin Will! Dankeschön, vielen Dank. Konnten wir es endlich einrichten? Am 17. haben wir es alle geschafft, hier zusammenzukommen. Schön, dass ihr alle Zeit habt. Ja, zur Show, die wahrscheinlich am häufigsten verschoben wurde in der Geschichte der Menschheit. Heute kommen wirklich nur Leute, die gar nichts vorhaben. Nie. Wenn man sagen kann, Sonntag kann ich, Montag kann ich. Ihr seid diese Leute aus dem Freundeskreis bei Doodle, die immer sagen, ja, ich kann nicht mal. Ja, genau. Einfach nichts vor, kein Privatleben, schön, dass ihr heute da sein konntet, kein Fliegenfischen, Taekwondo oder was auch immer man so an Hobbys hat, ich weiß es nicht genau. Hat jemand was verlegt hierfür, das würde mich interessieren. Oh, musste gelogen werden für heute Abend. Musste jemand was verschieben, war es ein riesen bürokratischer Arzt heute? Ja, hier vorne direkt, erste Reihe direkt die Lügner, hallo? Hallo, hey. Oh ja, heute ist das kurze Counter Strike ESL-Turnier, oh nein! Ah, scheiße! Ah, Simple gewinnt er ein Major, ja oder nein, ach Gott, große Frage! Aber du kannst ja so, wie so Amis bei so einem Baseballspiel einfach so dein iPhone laufen lassen und nebenbei einfach so ESL gucken. Aber das ist eine ganz dumme Idee, sich leider in die erste Reihe zu setzen, weil wir haben ein Auge für Smartphones, nicht dass Leute hier nebenbei wieder schön... Es war freie Platzwahl, dass überall geheim ESL gucken können. Wir alle wissen, letzte Reihe ist die sicherste, da kann man machen, was man will. Erste Reihe? Schwierig, kann sein, dass... Hey, hey, hey, hey, jetzt oben und reinge! Schon damals in der elften Klasse saß ich in der Loge schon. Aber hier, das ist auch ein bisschen dreist übrigens, so Weingläser auf der Bühne abzustellen. Nee, das geht nicht. Ich meine, ihr seid ja beim Podcast so, hier ist alles möglich, hier ist auch immer sowas möglich, sowas. Oh, okay. Geht dann nicht mehr. Also ich fühle mich eingeschränkt in der Kreativität. Aber heute ist glaube ich noch... Nein, macht's ruhig. Nein, macht's ruhig, bitte. Guck mal, ich gucke dir Florentin an, hier ist alles erlaubt. Ja, ist heute noch warm. Heute ist noch warm. Es gelten keine Regeln. Es ist ja... Moment, stopp, kurze, warte, langsam. Es ist nicht so, ich habe eine lange Hose dabei. Hat er. Ich habe mir zehn Minuten... Er hat gefragt, Fragen wurden gestellt. Ich habe mir zehn Minuten voraufs gedacht, es ist eine lockere Runde heute, es ist eine lockere Runde, die sind alle leger. Ich will ja euch immer das Gefühl geben, dass ihr unmöglich underdressed sein könnt, dass egal was ihr anzieht, ihr seid okay. Ja, und es ist ihr gelungen. Es ist mit dem Anlauf gelungen. Niemand schämt sich heute für sein Outfit. Aber ey, Fl Ausweichtermin. Ja, es ist auch. Es ist so ein bisschen entspannter. Wenn es sofort gewesen wäre und es hätte stattgefunden und so, ein bisschen gruselig, aufregend, aber es sind ja Ausweichtermin. Da kann man sich mal so anziehen. Wir sind auch nur die Ersatzpodcaster heute, Vertretungspodcaster, wir haben den Fernsehwagen da, also nach der Anmoderation geht es über. Ich merke aber tatsächlich, dass ich schamloser werde. Also jetzt zum Thema Kleidung, ich werde schamloser. Ich wollte gerade die Komplimente geben, weil deine Bands passen farblich wunderbar zu deinen Bermuda-Shorts. Nein, aber ich habe tatsächlich, bei der Hose habe ich oft das Problem, dass sie rutscht und dann muss man diese Kordel neu aufmachen und zu und ich habe gemerkt, dass ich in der Öffentlichkeit keinerlei Hemmungen mehr habe, diese Geste, also wirklich ich dachte, die ruhig dachen zu lassen. Ne, ne, eben nicht, das merke ich schon noch, aber im Edeka einfach so, ich stehe direkt hinter einer kleinen Familie, irgendwen einfach. Ich sage, du musst einfach den Druck erhöhen, du musst den Druck erhöhen. Aber es ist so weird, es gibt Leute, die haben dieses unter der Gürtellinie herumfummelt Bewusstsein der Öffentlichkeit und ich weiß nicht, wo das kommt. Nee, eigentlich brauchst du nicht. Brauchst du nicht. Ich glaube, das kommt auch mit dem Alter. Ich habe langsam das Gefühl, dass dieses Dad-Image schon langsam kommt. Mir ist alles scheißegal, egal wie ich aussehe, Sandalen, Socken, irgendwie kariertes Helm mit offenen Hosen. Dieses pragmatische, aufs Retter ausgelegt, auch rausgehen, die Jack-Wolfs-Gelack wird sich übergeworfen. Ja, mir ist einfach alles egal, komplett. Irgendwann habe ich einen Zollstock dabei, schön, dass er einfach immer weiß, wie lang irgendwas ist. Ich war noch nicht bei Ikea und habe hinten so einen Zollstock drin gehabt, ich habe mich so cool gefühlt, mit so einem Zollstock, so ich kriege Dinge hin bei mir zu Hause, ich mache Dinge selber bei mir zu Hause. Tatsächlich erwische ich mich auch dabei, dass ich Bock habe auf klassische Aktivitäten, ne, also klassische Mal was machen. Wir hören alle zu, wir hören alle gebangen zu. Und diese rhetorische Pause hat uns alle noch ein bisschen angespannt. Nein, nein, weil manchmal, also ich kenne das ja, man kommt von der Arbeit nach Hause, schuften die Kohle, man wäscht sich den Kohlestaub aus den Haaren und dann die ganzen. Wie kriegst du den am besten raus aus deinen Klamotten? Am besten einfach drin lassen für den nächsten Tag,, weil am nächsten Tag geht es wieder nochmal tiefer in die Mine rein und da sage ich immer, egal, was soll's. Und dann sitzt man da so da und denkt sich, was jetzt mit der Zeit, was mache ich jetzt? Aber tatsächlich haben sich ja Leute Gedanken gemacht, was man machen kann. Man kann ja Sachen machen, Aktivitäten. Zum Beispiel war ich letztens in einem Apfelgarten. Also einfach in so einem, ja wir haben Äpfel und ihr nicht und für einen kleinen Entgeltbetrag können wir dieses Verhältnis leicht ändern und wir kommen in den Apfelgarten. Also wie, was war so eine Sonntagsaktivität? So eine klassische Sonntagsaktivität. Bist du morgens aufgestanden? Ja, so als hätte ich eine Familie und müsste planen, weil ich glaube, das wird für mich wahrscheinlich so der grösste Einbruch, dann stehen die Kinder vor mir und sagen, was machen wir heute und du sagst ja heute ist ESL, Leute, was werden wir heute wohl machen, was glaubt ihr denn? So und dann so, ja nee, wir wollen was spielen, so ja, SpielCounts-Track. Aber wann ist die Idee entstanden? Ist die Idee eine Woche vorher, einen Tag vorher oder am gleichen Tag entstanden? Spontan. Spontan, in dem Moment. Spontan in den Apfelgarten. In dem Moment, exakt. Und vor allem, dann war ich in diesem Apfelgarten und man konnte Apfelbäume angucken und die Apfelbäume waren in Form eines Apfels gepflanzt. Also wenn du jetzt reichst, wenn du ein, wenn du ein, ein hungriger, angenommen, du bist ein hungriger Rabe und fliegst in sieben Kilometer Höhe und du siehst, oh, oh, oh, oh, das könnte was für mich sein. Das sieht für mich nach Apfelgarten aus. Und dann fliegst du näher und es ist orange und du denkst, fuck you, man. Genau. Und fliegst weg. Und ich mir dachte, wie krass kann man eine Pflanze eigentlich dominieren? Nicht als Mensch, nicht dass wir sie seit Jahrhunderten züchten und in Richtungen lenken, die nie angedacht waren. Züchtet doch den Kern weg. Nein, wir stellen dafür Äpfel in Form von Äpfeln auf. Aber es sagt für mich auch ein bisschen, dass sie sehr, sehr viel Zeit haben. Ja, wahnsinnig viel Zeit. Unterhalb auch Vorausplanung, dass sie wussten, man will hier irgendwann einen Apfelgarten bauen. Und es ist einfach, weil das ist so, das ist für mich ein bisschen respektlos. Das ist so, wie wenn so ein Chicken Nugget die Form eines Hühnchens hätte. So hat es ja aus Respekt nicht. Also ihr fragt euch, warum diese merkwürdigen Formen? Ich habe diese Bärchenwurst nie verstanden. Warum dann nicht wenigstens konsequent Schwein? Ne, das ist eben Respekt vor dem Tier. Das muss schon sein. Das ist Respekt vor dem Schwein, aber was hat der Bär damit zu tun? Der Bär ist so, was habe ich mit dieser Wurst jetzt zu tun? Ja stimmt, meinst du, im Wald kommen die Schweine so zum Bären und sagen so mit ihr so in Ausklappmessern so, erklär mal. Mit dem Ringelschwanz so. Wie ist das mit der Bärchensalami? Was ist da drin, mein lieber Bär? Du glaubst, dass so laissez-faire Schweine zum Bären gehen? Die kommen in Überzahl, die kommen in Überzahl, Ronny, Rocco, Spad und Pip und sagen, wir mischen jetzt mal den Bären auf. Ich habe damit nichts zu tun, sorry, ich habe damit nichts zu tun. Ich war neulich in so einem YouTube Rabbit Hole, also Bear Hole, YouTube Bear Cave. Ich weiß jetzt zumindest, man soll gegen Grizzlies, soll man sich totstellen und gegen schwarze Bären, soll man kämpfen. Da hat so einen Mann und das war so ein Kanadier und er war so super, er war nicht dieser American Guy, der einfach nur ein bisschen coole Content machen wollte und irgendwie so ein bisschen reisserisch sein wollte, sondern es war so ein super so ein Dad, der einfach besorgt war, um Leute, die da bei ihm in den Wildpark spazieren gehen und und sein Advice war, kämpft. Ja. Ich soll gegen diesen Schwarzbären kämpfen, weil er hat ja noch so Tipps gegeben, also woran man sieht, dass die aggressiv sind, weil die meisten Begegnungen mit Bären sind relativ entspannt. Können wir mal nachmachen. Die meisten Begegnungen. Du bist ein, ich bin jetzt mal ein Bär, du bist ein Mensch, der so in meinen Wald reinläuft. Der Wald gehört mir. Und dann gibt es die erste Begegnung, kurze Spielstopp. Okay. Ich war eh nicht zufrieden mit meiner Performance, von daher kam mir das ganz gelegen, dass wir nochmal von vorne ansetzen. Ich habe mich komplett verrannt. Es gibt die The Accidental Encounter, hat er es genannt. Okay. Wir rennen zufällig miteinander rein. Ich weiss von nichts, ich weiß von nichts. Obwohl ich ein Bär bin, hat nicht gemerkt, dass irgendwer in die Nähe kommt. Du als Mensch, der es auch besser wissen sollte, ein Bärgebiet ist, weißt auch nicht, dass ich hier bin. Ich weiß aber nicht, dass ich gleich ein Bär sehen werde. Es ist ein Accidental Encounter, ich mach das. Oh, oh, oh! Ist das schwarz oder braun? Äh, eine Sekunde. Schwarz. Okay. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Weil jetzt, jetzt musst du achten. Jetzt oder nie. Jetzt musst du, und jetzt hat er gesagt, nee, das darfst du nicht machen. Okay, sorry, Entschuldigung. Jesus Christ, ich habe dir gerade gesagt, du sollst noch nicht sofort kämpfen. Okay. Weil ich jetzt wirklich ank noch nicht sofort kämpfen. Weil ich mich ankommen und mich gegen dich kämpfen. Okay, das ist der Casual Encounter. Genau, das ist der Exzidentale Encounter. Wir haben uns beide erschreckt und so. Und jetzt ist die Frage, wenn ich jetzt nicht zum Beispiel um dich herum kreise oder anfange, dir meine Stärke zu zeigen, indem ich Bäume hochklettere. Angeber. Was ich auch dachte, weird flex, Bär. Wenn man eine Rückwärtssalto macht. Sondern eher so, auch meine Schnauze geschlossen halte. Dann musst du mit mir reden und musst sagen, hallo Bär, was geht denn, sag, dass du ein Mensch bist. Also ich weiß nicht warum. Okay, ich glaube, das ist offensichtlich, dass ich ein Mensch bin. Aber gut. Für mich als Bär, I know. Okay, okay, was soll ich sonst sein? Sondern dann gucke ich und dann gehe ich langsam weg. Und du solltest auch weggehen, aber nicht den Rücken zu drehen, niemals den Rücken zu drehen. Ciao, Bär. Ciao. Okay, zweiter Encounter. So retten wir Leben. Falls ihr heute auf dem, wir kennen die Fauna von Hannover nicht gut, also falls ihr auf dem Hause wegen Bären trefft. So, zweiter Encounter ist, ich wittere dich, du witterst mich nicht. Okay. Weil du bist ein Mensch. Okay, ich bin Method Actor, ich bin drin. Ich bin darauf vorbereitet. Sechs Jahre Schauspielstudium, kriege ich hin. Ich wittere nichts, okay. Höh, höh, höh, höh. Ich wittere nichts.
Was, was?
Ah, das ist die schwerste Rolle meines Lebens.
Ich wittere nichts.
Ja, aber wenn der Bär schreiend auf dich zuläuft. Okay, okay, sorry, ich dachte, das ist die Prämisse, dass ich nichts wittere.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, sorry, okay.
Method.
Okay, Entschuldigung.
Also du witterst nichts, aber erschreckst dich wie ein Mensch, wenn der Bär auf dich zukommt. Okay, sorry. So geht, ganz kurz, so gehst du durch den Wald. Du musst niemandem was beweisen. Solange ich nichts wittere. Sobald ich was wittere, muss ich das natürlich zeigen, wenn ich den Körper schraube. Noch w widere ich nichts.
Ein Bär! Nice. Okay. So, und jetzt musst du auf meine Sachen, auf gewisse Dinge achten. Zum Beispiel, wenn ich den Mund aufmache.
Ja.
Wütend. Wütend slash vielleicht bist du für mich Beute. Gut.
Dann diese Nummer mit dem Baum, wie gerade gesagt, dann um dich kreisen, alles super, super gefährlich anzeichichen und weil ich ein Schwarzbär bin, musst du was mit mir machen dann? Kämpfen. Richtig. Einfach all in, einfach all in, in dem Moment, das ist mein Moment. Ey, aber erstaunlich gut. Einfach auf Kopf-Schnauzhöhe. Aber es war erstaunlich athletisch und cool. Natürlich, das kann ich einmal pro Woche machen. Jetzt muss ich A gedrückt halten, bis ich wieder aufgeladen bin. Hast du jemals eine Combo gewusst oder hast du einfach Random auf Knöpfe gedrückt? Ich habe immer Random auf Knöpfe gedrückt. Hat irgendwer eine Combo mal gewusst? Ja, alle Button-Masher hier im Raum, sehr gut, sehr schön. Das ist übrigens die Tekkenmeisterin 2021, die zum Arm aller anderen E-Sportler gewonnen hat, indem sie immer nur A gedrückt hat. Kriegt man dann auch so einen Blumenstrauß, wie bei allen anderen Preisverleihungen? Aber bei so einem Shooter finde ich es irgendwie weird, wenn man dann so einen großen Blumenstrauß und so einen Pokal. Es kann schon sein, kommt darauf an, wie gross, ja, es kann schon sein. Großen Blumenstrauß. Großen Blumenstrauß, ja. Aber nochmal ganz kurz zu den Bären, weil kleiner, falls Bären im Raum sind, ich habe eine Idee. Weil es gibt ja wahrscheinlich immer so von den Bären, so wie bei so Mafia-Familien, immer so einmal im Jahr so ein Treffen, so Big Five. So der Vertreter der Eisbären, der Vertreter der Braunbären, der Vertreter der Schwarzbären. Und die kommen dann so zusammen und sagen, hey Leute, pass mal auf. So ein halb dunkler Raum. Ich bin der Braunbär übrigens. Wir Braunbären haben gemerkt, dass immer wenn wir Menschen sehen, dann stellen die sich tot.
Da können wir nichts machen. Da können wir gar nichts machen. Ganz kurz, Vertreter, der wird übersetzt eigentlich auch live. Der Vertreter der Schwarzbären äussert sich. Das ist Terrorpranke der Vertreter der Schwarzbären. Also, uns ist aufgefallen, dass wenn wir Menschen treffen, dann ist es in der Regel so, dass wir uns direkt angreifen und direkt kämpfen wollen. Ja, genau das habe ich gehört. Jetzt pass auf, angenommen, wir würden zusammenarbeiten. Braunbär plus Schwarzbär. Ja, ah, ne, ne! Dann hätten Menschen keine fucking Chance. Was würden die machen, wenn die gleichzeitig einen Braunbär und einen Schwarzbär sehen würden? Sich kämpfend totstellen. Totkämpfen, so die Zombie-Taktik dann einfach so. Ich bin tot um das Kämpfen. Warum machen Bären das nicht? Warum arbeiten die nicht zusammen? Es wäre so viel besser. Ja, ja. Ich glaube, es ist deren Verhängnis, dass sie nicht zusammenarbeiten. Ja, das ist klar. Es gibt die Schwarzen, die Braunen und die Weißen. Ja, das ist fucking, es wäre so viel besser. Ja, ja, ich glaube es deren Verhängnis, dass sie nicht zusammenarbeiten. Ja, die werden nicht zum Mond.
Es gibt die Schwarzen, die Braunen und die Weißen.
Ja, das ist fucking, es ist so schlimm, dass sie nicht zusammenarbeiten.
Die könnten zum Mond fliegen, wenn sie sich einfach nur zusammentun würden.
Das ist eine schöne Message eigentlich.
Sehr plump, aber so ein sehr plumper Disney-Film, so ein anti-racist, sehr plumper Pixar-Film.
Aber warum kamen dann gar keine Eisbären vor?
Ja, die sind ja Abholkappen oder so. Totgeschwiegen, ertrunken, so in einer Schale. Aber vielleicht wachsen die in Kiemen oder so, wer weiß, das ist Evolution. Vor allem, ich dachte immer, welchem Tier im Tierreich hielt es sich, totzustellen? Warum ist das überhaupt ein Ding, was manche Tiere machen? Aber es ist wirklich, da habe ich ein Video gefunden, es war wirklich eine lange Nacht, da habe ich ein Video gefunden, wie sich eine Antilope totgestellt hat und dann wurde ein Tiger vertrieben von Affen, es war wild. Die werden ja angelockt von toten Antilopen wieder. Die wiederum von Geiern, die ass, naja, dann kamen Affen und haben die Löwen vertrieben und dann war die Antilope, hat sich im Tod gestellt und war so, okay. Und dann haben die Affen die Antilope gerettet. Stefan, hast du das Dschungelbuch gesehen? Kann es sein, dass das keine Doku war, die du gesehen hast? Ja, dann war dieser Menschenjunge, hat gesungen. Die Olympiade der Tiere. Ich glaube, ich könnte mich sehr überzeugend im Tod stellen. Also ist jetzt natürlich eine... Naja, also nein. Nee, komm, komm. Das ist jetzt... Stell dich mal tot. Ihr wisst ja alle, dass ich nicht tot bin, also könnt ihr... Okay, aber angenommen... Ja, aber das denke ich beim Bär ja auch. Der Bär ist ja auch nicht bescheuert, das denke ich mir... Also lass uns nochmal, ich sitze auf meinem Campingstuhl und der Bär kommt heran und als Reaktion stelle ich mich tot.
Aber was ich jetzt auch schon denke, also ist ja auch schon laienhaft, sich liegen totzustellen. Hör auf, du sollst dich zu grinsen. So läufst du ja auch nicht rum.
Ich brauche das, um in die Rolle zu kommen. Aber das ist doch, wenn du, ich kenne dich ja in der Öffentlichkeit.
Du werschätzt meine Kunst überhaupt nicht, gar nicht.
Ich habe dich aus einem anderen Grund gecastet, weil hier drin schlägt das Herz eines Schauspielers. Okay. Außerdem habe ich dich privat draußen rumgehen sehen, ohne dass du es weiss, und du läufst nicht. Das ist nicht dein Gang. Das Geheimnis am Tod stellen, ich kann es jetzt schon mal sagen, Augen auf. Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das bei der Bärenkommission angekommen ist, dass Menschen die Augen auf haben. Man denkt immer, oh, da muss man die Augen zumachen, aber das stimmt nicht. Was denkt der Bär denn? Der Kota nimmt immer die Augen auf, deswegen gibt es ja diesen coolen Move, wenn man die Augen zumacht. Das stimmt, ja. Das stimmt. Okay? Okay. Trinkst casual aus Mikrofon, geil. Naja, warum geht man sonst campen, habe ich recht? Keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung. Keine Ahnung, wissen wir eigentlich. Keine Camp-Crawl. Okay, Achtung. Okay, ja, ich bin bereit. Und bitte. Aaaaaah! Haha! Und dann sagt der Bär so, ja. Und dann sagt der Bär, Zeitpunkt des Todes, 13.24 Uhr. Ich hoffe, er beerdigt mich. Dann so ein Klemmbrett. Und dann kriegen deine Eltern einen Anruf von Bären. Weird Dann kriegen die einen Anruf von Bern, der dem sagt, dass ihr Sohn verstorben ist, 13.24, und der nichts mehr machen konnte. Aber ich glaube, dann würde ich es auch komplett durchziehen. Wenn erst meine Eltern denken würden, ich wäre tot, dann würde ich die Situation in den Shop. Ah, dann würdest du Pranks machen. Ja, ja, dann würde ich es, naja, so fangen Pranks ja an, so dann passiert es und dann spielt man es einfach weiter. Und dann sagt man, nee, dann bin ich auch tot. Dann bin ich auch tot und dann macht Stefan das grosse Casting im Podcast-Ufo für einen neuen Co-Moderator und dann bewerbe ich mich unter falschem Namen. Dann bin ich irgendwie Garth Bingsey oder sowas und dann komme ich rein und dann bin ich der Neue und kann eine ganz neue Persönlichkeit starten, ganz neu anfangen. Wie würdest du dich anziehen dafür? Weil ich kenne dich, du hast Bock auf Prank, aber du bist auch faul. Ich glaube, dir würdest du nicht so viel Mühe geben bei der Verkleidung. Nein, ich will nicht auffallen, deswegen würde ich anziehen, eine kurze Hose und ein Futurama-Shirt. Ah ja. Ich glaube, damit kann ich relativ gut untertauchen, das ist ja niemand. Das macht Sinn. Würdest du weitermachen mit Podcasts, wenn ich tot bin? Nein, ich würde einen neuen starten, aber ich würde nicht mit Podcasts freuen. Krieg die Flasche nicht auf. Soll ich sie dir aufmachen? Soll ich sie dir aufmachen? Ich würde auf jeden Fall weitermachen, klar. Kein Problem. Ja, mach doch. Kein Problem. Und dann würde ich nacheinander jeden einzelnen von euch einladen, für jede Folge, solange bis alle durch sind. Ja, finde ich gut. Und dann können wir noch mal zusammen überstehen. Oh, keiner freut sich, sehr gut.
Auf den Moment habe ich gewartet.
Aber kann jeder Podcast am Anfang so ein
Memoriam über mich haben, mit einem
anderen Nachruf? Ja.
Sag mal so, Thais hat ja
schon einen Nachruf vorbereitet.
Auf uns beide, ja. Für jeden von uns, den wir nicht lesen durften.
Falls mal was passiert. Und wie ich mitbekommen
habe, eigentlich nur für uns beide, wenn wir beide
gleichzeitig bei einem Bär nun Glück sterben. Ja, wir gehen davon aus, dass wir beide gleichzeitig sterben. Ja, gehe ich echt davon aus. So ein Achterbahnunfall oder irgendwie sowas. Ja, oder so ein Scheinwerfer, der auf uns fällt. Oh ja. Hast du die Angst? Das ist wirklich unironische Angst von mir. Macht ihr das auch, wenn ihr in so einem, also stellt euch mal vor, ihr seid in so einem Veranstaltungssaal mit Scheinwerfern, überlegt ihr auch immer so, wer würde sterben, jetzt der, wenn der, macht ihr doch, oder, hat doch bestimmt schon jemand gemacht heute Abend. So wiegt die vielleicht, so zwischen die beiden. Hat sich jemand wirklich hingesetzt aus Angst vor einem Scheinwerferunglück? Oh ja. Vor einem bekannten Scheinwerferunglück. Gar niemand, okay, wir können es auch nicht sehen. Wir können nur die erste Reihe sehen, also wir können heute nur die. aber das wäre schon ein cooler Tod, oder, vom Scheinwerfer erschlagen.
Findet ihr, ihr trinkt schnell den Wein, den ihr auf die Bühne gestellt habt, oder ihr trinkt den näher? Seid ihr Schnelltrinker oder Langsame Trinker? Es geht.
Okay. Ja genau, weil weird jetzt, angenommen ihr trinkt schnell und dann aus der ersten Reihe aufzustehen und alle sehen den Grund, wir sehen den Grund, weil wir euch noch ein Glas besorgen.
Wir sollen euch ein Glas besorgen. Ich habe heute Abend nichts vor, also ich habe Zeit. Oder ihr könntet, ich sehe das immer so auf so Mitschnitten von so Rockkonzerten, von so Ringrock oder irgendwie so diese Sachen, wo dann immer so Ringrock 2022. Warst du da? Warst du bei Ringrock 2022? Ringrock! Yes! Ringrock mit Boys! Ringrock! Und dann steht da immer so irgendein krasser Typ auf der Bühne und dann werfen die Leute so ihre Drinks und der fängt das dann und ist cool. What? Und das könnt ihr ja auch machen. Falls die denn kein Getränk mehr haben, schmeißt einfach euers vor, ich fang das cool und dann könnt ihr weiter trinken. Ja, jetzt will ich mal sehen, was passiert. Werft eure Glasflaschen auf Florentin. So ein langes Strohalm. Kann man da auch machen, einfach so einen langen Strohalm mitbringen und dann so von anderen Leuten trinken. Das fände ich aber auch nicht schlecht. Ich glaube tatsächlich, wenn mir das passieren würde, ich würde mich nicht beschweren. Wenn ich wirklich ernsthaft im Kino sitze und ein Strohalm, ein großer Strohalm kommt von hinten, so lang, so auch so, weil man hat ja, ihr kennt das, wenn der Strohalm zu lang ist, hat man vorne kaum noch Kontrolle. Der wackelt, wackelt stark. Vor allem oft hast du ja auch Strohalm in Strohalm gesteckt. Ja, muss sein, muss sein. Und an irgendeinem Punkt knickt es leider. Ja, es gibt ja kaum noch Strohalm, also die letzten 20, die es gibt auf der Welt, wurden zusammengeführt und dann hast du ja vorne so eine grosse Schwingung und dann kommt es so in dein Sichtfeld rein, während du den Film anschaust. Und auch so gegen das Gesicht. Aber daran siehst du schon, wie gut der Pilot ist, weil es dann, wenn es sich so langsam einpendelt, dann geschickt drin ist. Genau, im richtigen Moment. Und dann darfst du auch als Bierhalter darfst du nicht sagen. Was machen Sie denn, sondern man muss auch gewähren lassen. Ja, ich würde es einfach gewähren lassen. Du kannst ja nicht sagen, Entschuldigung, können Sie bitte aufhören, aus meinem Kaltgetränk
mit ihrem riesigen langen Rüssel zu trinken.
Dankeschön. Kannst ja nicht machen, ich werde uns filmen.
Die Beschwerde wäre zu weird.
Oder mit so einem ganz kleinen Kescher ins Popcorn.
Ich habe gedacht, ganz war lang,
aber klein. Obwohl von oben, oder?
Die Loge kann das super machen.
Die Loge kann das richtig gut machen mit so einem kleinen Kescher.
Aber ich habe so einen Greifarm zum Beispiel.
So einen länglichen Greifarm.
Für welches weirde Hobby hast du dir das jetzt wieder gekauft? Welche Phase war das, als du dir den Greifarm gekauft hast? Möchte ich das nicht sagen. Du machst dich eh nur lustig. Stefan, ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich diesen Greifarm habe. Hast du Ocean's Eleven gesehen und wolltest irgendwie cooler Einbrecher, Dieb werdende, ja? Ja. Und hast du versucht, was du klauen? Ja. Was hast du geklaut? Popcorn. Popcorn, okay. Okay. Das ist praktisch. Aber hast du das nicht mal gemacht im Kino? Du bist ja so ein Popcorn-Fan. Das ist aber so ein Greifarm mitgenommen. Ich habe mir tatsächlich mal so einen Greifarm geklaut. Was? Wie? Mit einem Greifer? Entschuldigung. Da rasseln die Handschellen wieder der letzten Reihe. Nein, ich habe ihn gekauft.
Aber ich glaube, aus dem dümmsten Grund der Welt einfach.
Der dümmste Grund der Welt ist es ein bisschen peinlich, aber okay.
Hört die Person den Podcast, lass mich kurz mal überlegen.
Es war eine Person, eine junge Dame, sagen wir mal, der zu imponieren ich gedenkte.
Und die eines Tages Geburtstag hatte, was ich wusste durch intensive Stalking, aka facebook.com, geile Seite, probier's mal aus, lohnt sich. Facebook.com, Profilseite, Stalking. Und die hatte sich zum Geburtstag gewünscht, hat sie dann so geschrieben, ich wünsche mir, weil ich möchte keine Geschenke haben, nichts. Mein Wunsch für heute ist, dass jeder losgeht und Müll sammelt. Und dass durch meinen Geburtstag die Welt ein bisschen sauber wird. So, und dann dachte ich mir, komm, das ist jetzt meine Chance. Das ist die perfekte Frau. Das ist meine Chance. Und dann hast du gesagt, okay, jetzt bin ich mit dem Greifer.
Fahre ich zum Baumarkt, kauf die fucking billigste Greifzange aller Zeiten und was habe ich gemacht und es ist mir wirklich feinlich.
Lass mich raten, du hast das Selfie gemacht, wie du im Park stehst und so und dann hast du es dann nach wie ja, dann hast du wahrscheinlich so eine Dose aufgehoben, hast du das Selfie gemacht oder hast du noch jemanden mitgenommen, der dich wie zufällig fotografiert dabei bei deiner guten Tat und dann hast du die Dose wieder weggeworfen in den Park und bist mit dem Greifarm auch noch in den Park geworfen und bist nach Hause gegangen und hast gepostet. Ja, exakt das. Exakt das. Ich bin zum Hamburger Hafen gegangen und da gibt es so Stimme, wo so ganz viel
ran gespült ist und so und dann mache ich so, oh, hier am Strand ist so viel Müll und so und den
sammle ich jetzt heute ein, mache wirklich so eins in die Ikea-Tüte und dann so, okay, puh, ich muss los, Handy aus, wieder hingeworfen, eins Auto, das Auto, die Miete des Autos lief noch, der Motor lief noch, losgefahren und, der Motor war noch an, das ist so, so erfährt sie jetzt, dass ich tatsächlich rein gar nichts getan habe,, Frau Hund, das ist doch, also das ist doch genug, also allein so zu tun ist doch auch eine Geste, oder nicht? Naja, und dann aber, wie hat sie reagiert? Jetzt hat sie natürlich total gefreut, so, krass. Hat sie viele Bilder bekommen? Und dann dachte ich mir so, ja, ey, cool, das war wirklich mein neurotisches Gehirn, dachte direkt an, wenn es jetzt alles gut läuft mit ihr und so, keine Ahnung, dass sie dann sagt, ey, lassen Sie mal genau an dem Strand spazieren gehen, wenn ich in Hamburg bin. Und ich dachte mir so, fuck, und ich muss so in der Nacht vor dem Date dann einfach den gesamten fucking Strand sauber machen und meine Lüge wieder aufwärts sein. Aber es wäre so eine Curvy Enthusiasm-Folge eigentlich, wie sie merkt, dass du gar nicht so gut darin bist. Ja, genau. Dass du eigentlich jemand, der schon mal drei Dosen aufgehoben hat, wäre besser darin und du zeigst an deinem Verhalten, dass du gar nichts gemacht hast. Es war, ich bin nicht stolz drauf, extrem erbärmlich und diesen Scheißgreifer habe ich bis heute und er guckt mich an mit diesem schamvollen Blick des Du hättest die Welt besser machen können. Du warst am Strand, du hattest Zeit, aber du hast gar nichts gemacht, überhaupt nichts. Aber danke für deine Offenheit, dass du hier so uns allen teilst. Ja, gerne. Ihr kriegt ja nicht die weirden Nachrichten, die jetzt noch kommen mit. Aber ich frage mich gerade, ist es cool, sowas zu fordern, weil natürlich cool, wenn Leute das dann auch machen und so, aber es ist so, es ist auch ein bisschen weird. Aber es ist auch auf eine Art nett, aber ich finde es, ich habe mich gerade gefragt, weil oft wenn Leute was bei Facebook schreiben, sagt das eine Menge über die Person aus, aber das weiß ich jetzt noch nicht genau. Es ist doch das alte Problem mit diesem Scheiss, ich will keine Geschenke, dann geht man zum Geburtstag und alle haben Geschenke ausser du, weil du das ernst genommen hast, was die Personen gesagt haben, alle, ja, ich habe den Garten aufgeräumt, aber ich habe dir trotzdem hier noch eine Playmobil packen, ah, sie war elf, sorry, muss ich dazu sagen, ich habe dir hier trotzdem noch Playmobil gekauft. Sie war elf und hat gesagt, ich will keine Geschenke. Nein, nein, nein, kleiner Scherz, das mache ich manchmal.
Hier ist dann trotzdem noch dein Geschenk und du bist der Einzige, der nichts dabei hat.
Nein, du kaufst dir ein Geschenk, damit du nicht mehr über die Person nachdenken musst. Nimm einem diesen Anker doch nicht weg. Das ist super gemein. Was willst du mir zum Geburtstag schenken? Letztens habe ich irgendwas gesehen, wo ich dachte, Stefan will das... So ein Random-Shift. Ich habe es direkt vergessen. Ich glaube, es war so ein... Genau, es... Dann dachte ich mir, das ist genau so richtig für dich. Und zwar ist es... Es gibt manchmal das Problem, dass Leute in Hochhäusern wohnen und Angst haben, weil sie nicht wissen... Ich wohne nicht im Hochhaus, aber... Langsam. Stopp. Okay. Und Angst haben, weil sie sagen, oh Hilfe, wenn jetzt brennt oder so, die Leiter des Feuerwehrwagens ist nicht lang genug, keine Ahnung. Und deswegen gibt es kleine Fallschirme, die man sich kaufen kann. Geil. Die davon, wo man so sagt, so fünf Stock oder höher kann man runterspringen. Ich dachte mir, ja das ist doch genau was für ein Stefan, der nicht in einem Hochhaus wohnt. Aber ich weiß, dass auch du aus dem zweiten Stock dir denkst, naja, sicher ist sicher. Wie hoch muss man sein für Fallschirm?
Das weiss ich nicht genau. Da stand nicht drauf. Da stand sowieso drauf, niemals benutzen, vergesst es, wir nehmen überhaupt gar keine Verantwortung für irgendwas.
Das ist nur ein Ausstellungsobjekt zum Spaß.
Das war so eine klassische Facebook-Werbung, Nachricht, wo du auf irgendwelche taiwanesischen Shops kamst oder irgendwie sowas.
Ganz furchtbar, hätte auch nicht geklappt, wäre sofort gerissen. Aber da dachte ich mir, das wäre was für Stefan. Ich weiß nicht, was das über mich aussagt. Dass er auch immer so neben seinem Fenster, ja, weil du bist so ein bisschen überdramatisch. Und deswegen, dass du immer so neben dem Fenster immer so, ja, wer weiss, wer weiss, wenn was passiert, bin ich aus dem Fenster raus. Ja, in meiner Wohnung ist lustigerweise ein Riesen, haben Leute in ihrer Wohnung Feuerlöscher, habt ihr Feuerlöscher in deiner Wohnung? Ja, haben alle Menschen, es ist so, ich kriege so mixed signals von euch, die einen sind massiv am Kopfschütteln und die anderen ja. Könnt ihr mal kurz ein Handzeichen, wer hat einen Feuerlöscher bei euch in der Wohnung? Ich dachte auch gerade, aber überdramatisch hat er mich abgeholt. Wenig, ja wenig, also 20 Prozent, habe einen Riesenfeuerlöscher bei mir in der Wohnung und dachte mir auch ein bisschen, die Kanonen aufspaßen. Was heißt riesig? Schon Sonnhochschild. Ui! Und auch mit so einem Schild drüber, mit so einem Feuerlöscherschild drüber. Ich mag auch, wie Stefan ganz subtil betont, dass er eine sehr grosse Wohnung hat. Nee, das ist meine ich gerade. Habt ihr auch so einen riesigen Feuerlöscher, habt ihr auch diesen Schlauchanschluss direkt in eurer Wohnung, Weil du musst ja in den Südflügel und in den Nordflügel auch kommen. Also wie sonst. Ich meine den Westflügel, jetzt unter dem Hermelin, habt ihr da auch. Aber nee, deswegen meine ich ja überdramatisch, weil er sehr gross ist für die Wohnung. Und ich weiß nicht, was da für ein Feuer entstehen soll, aber okay, 20% haben ungefähr auch ein Feuerlöscher in der Wohnung. Nee, ich habe auch ein Feuerlöscher und das erste, was ich gemacht habe, ist, den komplett zuzustellen mit irgendwelchen Sachen, so dass wenn es brennen würde, ich sagen würde, ach, fuck it. Mit höchst brennbaren Dingen hast du in den Feuer gestellt. Ja, ich habe immer noch Wasser zu Hause tatsächlich, bin ein bisschen paranoid geworden, weil tatsächlich vor kurzer Zeit bei mir das Wasser abgestellt wurde, einfach. Die haben einfach gesagt, kein Bock mehr, du kriegst kein Wasser mehr. Weil du nicht gezahlt hast? Naja, Wasser ist für alle da, Wasser ist für alle da, das war schon. Die haben mir zwei Tage im Vorhinein gesagt, wir werden ihnen das Wasser abschneiden. Haben sie mir gesagt? Haben sie mir gesagt und dann war ich im Survival-Mode einfach, dann war ich wirklich Seven vs. Wild einfach Castaway direkt so, ich habe gegoogelt, wie macht man Feuer, wie kann man aus Läusen Milchshake machen, keine Ahnung, einfach Sachen, die man braucht in der Natur und dann habe ich aber präventiv mir gedacht, naja gut, wenn in zwei Tagen mein Wasser weg ist, sammle ich ab jetzt so viel Wasser wie möglich und habe einfach jedes Gefäss in meiner Wohnung, wirklich jedes, randvoll mit Wasser gefüllt. Badewanne, jede Flasche, die ich gefunden habe, jedes Glas, jeder Topf, sogar jeden flachen Teller habe ich und habe überall in meiner Wohnung die hingestellt, weil ich dachte, ey, man weiß nie, so viel Wasser wie es geht. Hast du den Film Science gesehen von Unmatch Samalan? Ja. Wo irgendwann überall, du siehst auch wie ein Verrückter, der dann sieht, weil Aliens kommen, alles voller Wasser stellt. Genau, aber weil am Ende waren ja... Alte Referenz, sorry. Naja, man muss dazu wissen, die Schwachstelle der Aliens war am Ende tatsächlich Wasser. Und das heißt, da wäre ich perfekt, wenn ich einfach vor jede Tür Wasser gesteckt hätte. Und dann kam der besagte Tag, was ich natürlich nicht vergessen habe, ist, dass wenn ich kein fließendes Wasser habe, dann dachte ich einfach, ja, hier, dann nimmst du dir halt so einen Topf und dann duschst du dich damit. Vergessen habe ich, dass das Wasser natürlich eiskalt wird, so, und ich habe mich halt zwei Tage dann nicht gewaschen, aber tatsächlich habe ich bis heute noch einige von diesen Gefässen übrig, weil ich bin ja sau faul, wenn dann das Wasser läuft, als ob ich dann rumgehen würde und jede Mr-Max-Flasche wieder ausleeren würde. Nein, die stehen noch voller Wasser bei mir rum. Das heißt, ich habe tatsächlich aktuell locker 30, 40 Liter Wasser parat. Das heißt, ich brauche gar keinen Feuerlöscher, sondern ich kann einfach... Wie Preppy. Wie ein Trekkie? Preppy. Ach so, wie ein Trekkie-Preppy. Das ist nochmal so das Wenn-Diagramm von Trekkies und Preppern. Die haben nochmal so eine ganz eigene... Das ist eine grosse Schnittmenge, glaube ich. Ich habe alle DVDs The Next Generation im Bunker. Könnte ich die ganze Zeit schauen. Ja, weil ich habe ja ein paar Freunde in der Schweiz und die haben alle einen Luftschutz... Jeden Schweizer, das habe ich immer gehört und dann die gefragt, ob das stimmt, jeder Schweizer hat einen Luftschutzbunkerplatz. Wenn mal irgendwas passiert, hat jeder aus der Schweiz einen Luftschutzbunkerplatz. Und die auch. Und alle aus dem Freundeskreis haben einen Luftschutzbunkerplatz. Darf man da auch normal hingehen, wenn nichts ist? Genau. Da darfst du einfach immer hingehen. Das ist eine Urlaubswohnung. Genau. Das ist ja geil. Ich weiß nicht, es ist halt ein sehr kalter Keller. Aber ja, ländliche Urlaubswohnung. Und da haben die jetzt auch einer angefangen, weil einer, und das verstehe ich auch, weil das zirnt natürlich so, das macht man so Preppy-Dinge und der hat ganz viel Wasser sich gekauft und da hingestellt. Und dann läuft das halt ab und dann tritt er das aus und er hat sich neues Wasser und stellt es da hin. Da freut er sich bestimmt das ganze Monat drauf. Oh, heute wird er das abgelaufene Wasser trinken.
Los geht's.
Ich habe mich da ein bisschen drüber lustig gemacht.
Und dann guckt man sich die Weltpolitik an und dann irgendwann denkt man so, ich bin der Erste, der bei denen anruft und mich dann so reinzecke in einen so einen Luftwitzbunker.
So ein Gloss Wasser mal, einfach nur zur Seite stellen, dann fühlt man sich sicher.
Wir haben übrigens Nachrichten bekommen von einem Schweizer tatsächlich, weil wir haben
ja letzte Folge die sehr kontroverse Frage gestellt, was tun, wenn die Katze mordet. Ist die Folge schon rausgekommen? Ist ein Thema, ja. Echt? Gestern? Heute ist Sonntag. Und da kam die Frage auf, darf man sein Haustier einfach so einschläfern, weil man keinen Bock mehr drauf hat. Und hat geschrieben ja in der schweiz geht das aber in der schweiz kann kann man sich auch selber einschläfern die haben kein problem mit schlaf im allgemeinen einfach so wieder darf schlafen stellt sich raus in deutschland geht das nämlich nicht da braucht man also sein haustier einzuschläfern guten grund okay aber mein baby die kat die katze hat mein baby umgebracht. Reicht das jetzt aus? Hallo, Herr Doktor?
Ja, hallo. Hi, das ist meine Katze. Ah, ist die süss. Ja, die ist mega süss, hat gerade mein Baby umgebracht.
Oh, okay. Deswegen wollte ich Sie mal vorbeibringen und fragen, was jetzt so geht. Sie ist schon in der Gittern?
Ja, Sie wissen ja, wir sind ja hier in Deutschland in, weiß ich, Bern, Hannover, Bern, Deutschland.
Yes! Was für ein Zufall.
Keine Stadt hat so wenig für die eigene Stadt gejubeln müssen.
Niemand hasst seine eigene Stadt so sehr wie an.
Insane. In jeder anderen Stadt, yes!
Oh, ja, ich will ja! Und hier Hannover, hey!
So gelernt auch. Ja, wir sind ja hier in Hannover leider, und deswegen ... Wuh! Wuh! Wacke! Wacke! Wir sind ja hier in Hannover, das heisst, Sie bräuchten schon einen guten Grund, dass so ihre Katze ... Ja, wie gesagt, genau, weil sie hat mein Baby. Ja, aber sie haben noch ein Kind. Ja, aber es war halt noch ganz klein und super süss. Die kleine Luisa. Da bräuchte ich dann doch noch ein bisschen mehr. Die kleine Luisa, ich hab mir ein Bild gemacht, weil die hatte dann irgendwie noch dieses rosa Fliege in den Herchen. Und dann einfach draufgelegt. Geben Sie mir noch ein bisschen was, noch ein bisschen was obendrauf. Die Katze hat mal meinen ganzen, ich habe so einen Ordner, ich bin Controller, und dann hatte ich zuhause ein bisschen Arbeit, in der Coronazeit hatte ich so ein paar Sachen mit nach Hause und ein bisschen Arbeit mit nach Hause. Weiter, weiter. Und dann, das habe ich mir gar nicht in den Terminkalender gepasst, aber dann kam die Katze und hat einfach diesen Orten, als er flattert. Bring sie um das Milchstück, sofort! Sofort! Du brauchst mindestens zwei Straftaten, das die Gnaden regeln. Gibt es einen Grund, irgendwann in Deutschland kippt es da und man kann die Katze umbringen. Aber das kann jeder Tierarzt selber entscheiden. Wenn du einen Tierarzt findest, der Tiere hasst, dann hast du ihn sechst. Aber auch dann die Frage an sie, warum sind sie Tierarzt geworden? Aber gut, die Lehrer, die Kinder hassen, wollen Sie auch, warum die Lehrer geworden sind? Um Kinder zu ärgern. In keinem anderen Beruf habe ich so oft die Chance, Tiere umzubringen. Okay. Weil der Beruf des Tierarztes besteht zu 80 Prozent daraus, Tiere umzubringen. Was glauben Sie denn, wenn Sie mit Ihrem Haarbicht hier ankommen, mit gebrochenem Flügel? Meinen Sie, wir machen Flügelgips? Nee, da wird einmal, da kommt einmal Doktor Schuh in den OP und dann ist Schluss. Das ist der ganze Job. Das ist der ganze Job. Und ich liebe es. Und ich Ich liebe es. Können Sie sich Harbi mal angucken? Ja. Oh, was hat er denn?
Er humpelt. Wenn er geht, aber er geht halt selten. Ja, ja, ja. Er fliegt halt die meisten Zeit. Nee, müsste man leider einschleppen. Aber auch so ein Tierarzt, der so eine Uhr bei sich hat, so wie viele Tiere er schon umgebracht hat, wie so eine Schuldenuhr. Care points, noch 500, dann höre ich auch. Er war so packt mit dem Teufel geschlossen oder sowas. Wo war denn neulich noch mal so eine Uhr? Irgendwo habe ich so eine Uhr gesehen. Bahnhof? So eine riesen Schuldenuhr. Ich glaube, es waren so verkaufte Döner oder sowas, wo ich so dachte, weiss nicht, brauche man jetzt nicht. Wo läuft das dann die ganze Nacht? Das war meine erste Frage.
Die würde ich mir nicht als Armbandversion holen.
Irgendwann kommt ja noch eine neue Uhr.
Glaubst du?
Ich glaube schon, Zeit ist ein Konzept, das langsam ausgedient hat.
Wirklich?
Klar, im Mittelalter sagt man so, wann gehen die Kreuzzüge los, eine Stunde noch, da brauchst du Zeit.
Das ist eine Sonnenuhr, die du gehabt hast.
Genau, dann sagst du, ich habe noch eine Stunde Zeit,
um an Cholera zu sterben, dann gehst du los.
Jetzt geht's los.
Das war praktisch.
Genau, ich muss leider los, es ist schon so spät.
Schon so spät.
Schon abends leider.
Dieses Konzept der Sonnenuhr funktioniert nicht.
Nachts geht gar nichts.
Aber das ist eh komisch, warum hat man nur Zeit an der Hand?
Also du hast keinen Raum, keine vierte Dimension. Aber das kam ja jetzt neu. Jetzt mit Fitness-Armbändern und so. Ja, so Herzschlag und so. Genau. Herzschlag, zieh mehr Dinge auf. Verbrannte Kalorien. Verbrannte Kalorien. Ne? So ein Notknopf, irgendwas und so. Wann kommt als nächstes die Döneruhr? Oder einfach so, was ist das nächste Feature der iWatch, Apple Watch, der, Jesus, nicht von diesem Planeten ist, der schlechteste Apple-Chef. Rockring. Ich habe meine Eye-Watch auf dem Rockring verloren, Leute.
Ja, liebe Erdlinge, was wir... Gute Luft, die wir atmen, oder? Oh, die Luft ist heute gut. Ich liebe das. Ich liebe das, ja. Aber irgendwann kommen dann neue Features. Weil ich sag mal so, dem iPhone gehen langsam die Features aus. Was soll da noch rein? Da ist schon alles drin. Bei der Apple Watch auch. Irgendwann sagt man, packt da die Schuldenuhr rein von Darmstadt, dann die Döneruhr, fuck it einfach, jetzt kannst du dann alles so durchswappen. Warum sagt einem Kopfhörer nicht die Uhrzeit ab und zu? Ja. So jede halbe Stunde so, es ist genau fünf Uhr. Weißt du, weil es dieses Video immer läuft, genau so gesagt. Weil es wahrscheinlich fucking nervig ist, einfach die ganze Zeit. Einfach konstant.
Das stimmt. Aber könnte einem
nicht irgendwie so Infos geben, so Wind
oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung? Oder was man
sagen soll. Oh ja, das wäre gut.
Die KI hört mit
und das Gespräch, ja.
Du kaufst Brötchen und so und dann hast du
so eine Gag-Hilfe, so eine App angestellt,
die dich ein bisschen lustiger macht
im Alltag. So was darf es sein bei Ihnen.
Ja, ich hätte gern zwei normale, bitte.
Ja.
Wer hat die Kopfhörer drin?
Du.
Ich?
Kaufen Sie jetzt die neuen AirPods.
So gut, wir müssen keine gute Werbung machen.
Improv Geniuses.
Wer hat die Kopf...
Aber Mikrofon auch nicht wegnehmen.
Okay, ist schwierig.
Ich hätte gerne zwei Nummer.
Alles klar, bitteschön.
Ja, sonst noch was, der Herr?
Ähm...
Entschuldigung, die Schlange ist lang. Können Sie bitte ... Entschuldigung, was sagt die ... Ich habe hier, glaube ich, kein Internet. Die Apple Watch. Nächstes Jahr kommt die neue Version. Stark.
Ja, aber das fände ich nicht so schlecht. Wie bei, wie Mickey Beisenherz das bei Joko und Klaas macht, in den Live-Shows, ab und zu mal so ein Gag auf die Ohren und dann ist man mega hilarious. Und dann die Bäckerinnen denken auch, what, der ist so lustig geworden in der letzten Woche. Ich glaube, ich bin ohnehin beliebt bei Bäckern, muss ich sagen. Also, nee, nee, nee, nicht, nee, nee, nicht jetzt wegen der 2,40 Bullshit-Geschichte, nein, da möchte ich nicht überdrehen, weil ich mache etwas, das viele Bäcker und Bäckerinnen wertschätzen, und zwar könnt ihr auch machen, es ist so leicht, es ist so leicht, einfach neue Leute kennenzulernen, beliebt zu sein, ihr müsst einfach nur Müll sammeln und wenn ihr beim Bäcker seid, sagt, bevor ihr bestellt, wie viele Teile es insgesamt hat. Ja, ja, ja. Weil das ist nämlich der Kram eines jenen Bäckers, weil der muss sich ja, du sagst, ich hätte gerne zwei von denen und am Tonfall muss der jetzt entdecken, ist das der Anfang einer langen Reihe, bleibst dabei, wie viel Hunger hat die Person gerade und dann muss die Tüte ausgesucht werden, ist die kleine, mittlere oder grosse und dann verzettelt man sich oft kleine und dann oder ganz schlimm natürlich, ich hätte gerne zwei von denen, grosse Tüte und das war's.
Ja genau.
Und deswegen sage ich immer, es werden zwölf Teile und zwar drei von denen, vier von denen und acht von denen, bin ich gut in Mathe. Vor allem alle hinter dir. Ich habe gerade noch Hunger bekommen. Und dann sieht man so, dass alle hinter dir in der Reihe anfangen schon so, fuck, so panisch Kopf zu rechnen. Was zählten Franzbrötchen? Wurzel aus Knacker, Knacker, Becker, Becker.
Quarkbällchen ist es ein halbes Brötchen, wie viel zählt, was der Unbrusikur ist.
Die Weltmeisterbrötchen sind ein bisschen kleiner, das sage ich ja jetzt ein, aber es ist auch eigentlich nur Platz für den Halben.
Wobei, ich mache mich auch wieder unbeliebt, indem ich nämlich streng darauf poche, und auf dem Hügel würde ich sterben, dass salziges und süsses nicht in dieselbe Tüte gehören.
Ja, ja, ja, meine Damen und Herren! Ich habe keine Angst, es auszusprechen, dass dieser Wahnsinn aufhören muss, dass wenn ich sage, ich hätte gerne eine Brezel und ein Wuppi... Nee, nein, zieh es durch, zieh es mit dieser Wahlsprung Energie durch. Nein, wenn ich zum Becker gehe und sage, ich hätte gerne Brezel und Zimtpupin, dann kann es doch nicht sein, dass in diesem Land eine Tüte nur verwendet wird, wo zwei angemessen sind, meine Damen und Herren. Es müssen zwei, es liegt am Salz, am Salz! Der Brezel tut der Wuppi doch nicht weh, aber der Wuppi leidet unter dem Salz der Brezel, das ist doch das Bäcker-Ein-Mal-Eins. Ich denke, wie du noch mehr bescheuerte Burchen-Armen aufzählst in deiner Rede. Wie sauer kann man Wuppi sagen. Fucking Wuppi. Wuppi ist einfach furchtbar. Aber es ist einfach, und da mache ich mich mal unbeliebt, weil ich sage eine Brezel, ein Wuppi tut beides in eine Tüte und ich sage, kann ich vielleicht getrennte Tüten haben? Oh, aber du wirst nicht gefragt. Dann wird noch mal augenrollend rausgenommen. Augenrollen, wirklich? Ja, ja. Weil mein Bäcker fragt vorher, wie viel wird es denn insgesamt? Oh, du glücklicher, Grosse Wohnung und ein guter Bäcker. Guter Bäcker, Riesenwohnung. Du lebst das Leben. Und ein fucking Feuerlöscher. Du lebst das Leben. Ich weiss, wie man gegen Bären überlebt. I'm the genius of the world. Scherfantize, meine Damen und Herren. Wir werden alle so gern. Dann hast du einen guten Bäcker. Niemand ist so wie er. Dann hast du einen guten Bäcker. Ja. Fragt vorher, wie viel wird es denn insgesamt? Auch bei einer Eisdiele wichtig übrigens. Oh, du hast es so gut, ey. Oh, du hast es so gut. Einen Tag, ich würde gerne, können wir nicht für so eine romantische Komödie einen Tag Körper wechseln? Einen Tag, ich würde dich gerne dein Leben leben. Ja, ich will auch dein Leben gerne mal führen. Ja, weiss ich nicht. Viel Wasserbehälter einfach. Ja, an die muss man sich, glaube ich, gewöhnen. Na, sch, einfach so gehe ich jeden Tag mit dem Boden. Kleine Gänge, stelle ich mir vor, ganz schmale Gänge. Aber ist tatsächlich so, also ab einem gewissen Punkt habe ich auch gesagt beim Staubsaugen, ich sauge halt die Wege. Also, ich sauge die Wege und sonst nichts. Warum soll ich denn eine Ecke saugen, wo ich nie bin? So, da bin ich nie. Warum soll ich mir denn die Zeit aufwenden? Das heißt, man muss sich eine Wohnung vorstellen. Nie, in der Ecke, aber nie. Ganz neue Wohnung. Man muss sich vorstellen, weil angenommen, manchmal gibt es ja, Strassen werden ja so gebaut, dann im rechten Winkel, dann hat man ja oft dann so eine grüne Wiese. Und man sieht so einen Wald, so einen plattgetretenen Pfad, sieht man dann immer die Abkürzung, weil Menschen sind faul. Menschen gehen nicht, wenn man sich Radweg geht, bei jeder Grünfläche ist dann da ein Pfad. Du musst mir kurz den Moment geben, denn ich habe gestern gelernt, wie so ein Pfad heisst. Er heisst Desire Path. Ja, ich kenne deinen Fachbegriffen. Desire Path? Ich kenne, ich habe es gestern, ich habe es ohne Witz gestern gelernt. Ich bin so froh, dass ich das anwenden kann. Ich bin auch ein bisschen klug. Du hast es gelernt gestern und dachtest dir, das kann ich jetzt vergessen, weil ich will es niemals brauchen. Heute ist dein Moment. Heute ist der Tag. Wollen wir uns noch ein bisschen zelebrieren, oder wollen wir darüber reden? Das war in Ordnung. Die ersten vier Reihen waren dabei, der Rest hängt noch ein bisschen hinterher. Aber nein, ich bin realistisch, also ich mache dann auch wirklich die Kurven, die ich normalerweise gehe. Man sieht es ja an den Mayo-Spuren, sieht es ja, wie ich immer laufe. Wie so eine Schnecke. Kann man ja noch in hunderten von Jahren archäologisch rekonstruieren, wie damals, wie auch immer wir dann heißen, wie Eisenzeit, sind wir immer noch in der Eisenzeit? Nee, Kobalt. Kobaltzeit. Die Kobaltzeit. Nee, wie heißt das, was in den iPhones ist? Doch Kobalt, Quarz, Wismut, solche Sachen, yes! Wie heißt das, was im iPhone ist, was man nicht will?
Nochmal! Silizium! Ohne sieben! Silizium! Es wird die Lösung reingeworfen und wir sagen es immer noch falsch.
Wir wären so schlecht bei Velvet Millionär, wären wir so schlecht bei dem Zusatzjoker. Dann sagt dann jemand, ja, ich weiss es, und zwar ist das Silizium, undizium, B, Lithium, C, R, Lithium, D, Dulizium. Nee, das ist Kobalt, einfach. Wie gesagt. Sorry, ich freue mich einfach. Soll ich schon mal aufstehen? Hast dich verdankt. Danke. Hast dich verdankt. Weiß gar nicht, welche Musik kommt, wenn man gewinnt bei Wetten, Wer wird Millionär? Wer wettet das? Die neue Sendung. Aber es kommt nicht so häufig vor, dass jemand gewinnt, deswegen weiß man es nicht. Der Anfang ist die schnellen Fragen, die so weggesnackt werden. Und dann wird es mega nervig, wenn man es für sich genommen hört. Es gibt diese Playlist nämlich bei YouTube. Es ist auch Stephans A Cappella Show, einfach so Stomp für so Hintergrund. Aber macht mal, wenn ihr so eine Feier hat, ein paar Leute bei euch zu Gast und so. Und macht mal die Wärme-Millionär-Playlist an. Ja, und alle so direkt on edge, so fuck ey, hoffentlich geht mein Bruder ans Telefon. Wie war gestern, wie war dein Wochenende und dann so, ähm, a, es war sehr gut. Es ist nicht, b, ich hatte ein Date, das kann ich schon mal direkt sagen, b kann ich schon mal direkt ausschliessen. Dann würde dir vielleicht 50-50-Joker helfen. Ich schwank gerade noch zwischen A und C. A, ich hatte eine schöne Zeit. C, ich habe den ganzen Tag nur YouTube-Videos gesehen und Eis gegessen. Und die den ganzen Tag masturbiert. Ja. Ich glaube, ich rufe meinen Bruder Harry. Der kennt mich besser als ich. Der kennt mich gut. Kennt dich deine Brüder besser als du dich selbst? Nein, der ist jetzt wieder so ein Scheiß Stefan-Trei, keine Ahnung. Du bist der, der sich selbst am wenigsten kennt. So ist Stefan privat. Ihr denkt immer so, das ist eine Gag-Kanone und dann triffst du dich mal auf eine Pizza Hawaii bei ihm Abend. Nee, wenn die Show vorbei ist, sag ich. Er hat einen Pizzaofen. Und dann sitzt man bei ihm zu Hause und dann kommen solche Fragen um die Ecke. Nein, stimmt nicht, wir haben noch nie Privatzeilen verbracht. Aber bist du vorbeikommen? Außer dieser eine Abend, dieser eine herrliche Abend. Ja, ich weiß. Und da sind wir zu weit gegangen und dann hätten wir es rückwärts gelassen. Und dann haben wir gesagt, nein, der Podcast ist wichtiger als wir. Wir dürfen den Podcast nicht zerstören. Wir können jetzt kein Kind kriegen oder so. Das geht nicht. Wir haben ein Kind und das heißt DPU. Das Podcast U-Bru. Für alle, die noch nicht so viele Folgen gehört haben. Für alle, für die, dass hier heute die erste Folge ist, die durch Hannover geschlendert sind und sich dachten, ach ja, warum nicht? Erstmal sorry, sorry, dass es ausgefallen ist. War es für irgendwen wirklich ein Hustle, heute herzukommen? Ja, hey, sorry. Nee, nee, so schlimm kann es nicht sein, wenn das die Tonlage ist, in der man antwortet. Für wen war es richtig ein Hustle? Ja, für mich. Nee, so klingt gut nicht, mein Lieber. Ich habe das studiert sechs Jahre lang. Wenn du so richtig viel aufgewandelt hast, um herzukommen, dann ist das in etwa die Tonlage. Bist du erschöpft. Ja, die Erschöpftung war gut gespielt. Sorry. Nein, tatsächlich haben wir einige Nachrichten bekommen von Leuten, die nicht kommen konnten, deswegen jetzt eine Schweigeminute für alle, die heute nicht kommen konnten. Sie sind nicht tot, ich wollte das mal klarstellenstellen, die haben nur keine Zeit oder Privatleben oder halt. Schweigeminute, Schweigeminute. Guck mal, irgendwann muss man immer reinladen. Wir machen es jetzt so lange, bis wir es schaffen! Okay, dann fangen wir doch mal an, alles klar. Und das geht ab jetzt. Gucken wie Mirko das gefällt. Und ab jetzt. Ja, ist euer ... Alles klar, gut, wir haben Zeit. Hey, uns ist das wirklich egal. Wir, ihr habt dafür Geld bezahlt.
Ja, wir nicht.
Also nicht so viel, wir müssen auch sein.
Und wir probieren uns ein viertes Mal.
Glaubst du wirklich, wir kriegen das, glaubst du wirklich, dass es klappt?
Ja, fragt uns, fragen die Leute hier.
Okay, und go. Shh. Thank you. Ja, sorry an alle. Ja, Entschuldigung. Ihr seid in unseren Herzen Wahnsinn, alle, die heute nicht dabei sind. Wahnsinn, Respekt. Wir haben nur fünf Anläufe gebraucht, das ist knapp Kindergartenlevel, das ist schon nicht schlecht. Aber auch hier die Frage, wie lange hätte man das machen müssen, bis immer Leute gehen? Genau, bis irgendwelche Leute sagen, deine Uhr ist kaputt offensichtlich, das ist jetzt vier Minuten lang gewesen. Nee, aber auch so, wie oft hätten wir es dann wiederholen müssen und so, bis wir irgendwann zehn Minuten gar keinen Content mehr machen. Wie lange würde es dauern bis in der erste Richtung gehen? Uns sind diese Leute sehr am Herzen, die heute zuhause bleiben müssen.
Schade, dass ihr nicht da seid. Aber jetzt können wir bei euch lästern.
Ihr habt echt hässliche Instagram-Profile, also wirklich, muss man auch mal sagen, richtig hässlich, richtig hässlich.
Also wir mögen euch ja alle gern, aber manchmal hat man das Gefühl, ihr wart noch nie auf einer Veranstaltung,
was wir teilweise für Fragen kriegen im Vorhinein.
Ja, schaut dort an den Typen, der dreimal gefragt hat, an jeden, wo er ins Privatmama geschrieben hat, ob es ihr ein Klo gibt. Ja, ich meine, wir wissen es nicht. Ja, wahrscheinlich ja. Erstmal vielen Dank, man will aber auch nicht arschig rüberkommen, deswegen sagt man sowas wie ja, erstmal vielen Dank für die Frage. Den glauben ja, liebe Grüße, aber ich auch so, wenn man den zu einer WG-Party einlädt, ich mag auch dieses Prepped sein, dieses Vorbereitet sein auf alle Eventilitäten. Wenn es kein Klo gibt, ist es vorbereitet. Ihr alle habt jetzt gelacht über ihn, wenn es hier kein Klo gäbe, dann würde dir niemand lachen. Oder dann sieht das klassische, kann ich meinen Rucksack mitnehmen? Dann denkst du so, ja. Ja, dann würde dir niemanden lachen. Oder dann sieht man das klassische, kann ich meinen Rucksack mitnehmen.
Dann ist so, ja. Es gibt keine Rucksackpolitik hier, dass man dann sagt, nee, alle werden rausgeschmissen mit dem Rucksack. Der sagt so, ich muss meinen Rucksack mitbringen. Ich will nicht, dass ich dann vor dem Veranstaltungsort meinen Rucksack in den Müll werfen muss, nur um einzukommen.
Das ist mir einmal am Flughafen passiert, nie wieder. Das ist mir einmal bei Ringrock passiert. Schlimmste Ringrock 1974. Kann ich meine gelbe Hose anziehen? Willst du unsere modische Meinung oder willst du unsere... Nein, ihr seid alle herzlich willkommen. Vielleicht ist es ja auch die erste Veranstaltung von jemandem heute.
Das erste Mal wirklich außer Haus.
Ja, wie wir festgestellt haben, wir haben sehr junge Hörer. Genau, wir haben Kinderhörer, ja, tatsächlich. Die waren sehr, sehr wütend, als wir gesagt haben,
oh, ist verboten, hat da jemand geklatscht?
Wir haben ein Kind da.
Ja. Oh, hallo, Kind!
Ein Kind!
Herzlich willkommen! Hallo!
Sehr schön.
Das hieß ja gar nicht. Wow.
Ich bin mir... Sehr gut. Ich bin mir recht sicher, dass die Fans schon um 18 ist. Oh, oh, oh. Müssen wir noch ein paar Gags dir erklären, hast du irgendwas nicht verstanden? Aber hast du gefragt, ob es ein Klo gibt? Weil das... Das könnten wir verstehen. Würde ich verstehen, auf eine Art. Okay, ab jetzt... Kinder kennen sich noch nicht. Ab jetzt kinderfreundlicher Content, okay? Stefan, diesen zotigen Humor, diesen schlüpfigen Humor will ich jetzt nicht mehr von hören.
Diese zotigen Feuerlöscher, Bits und so, das war alles ein bisschen zu krass.
Wir sind ja bekannt für den zotigen Humor.
Ich liebe Skateboards, muss ich sagen.
Ich auch.
Und diese riesigen Lollis, die können nicht gross genug sein für mich.
Ich liebe es, wenn die so gross sind, dass ich meine gesamte Kindheit daran lecken kann.
Und danach ist die Zunge ganz rot. Oder blau.
Das erste Lecken mit sechs, das letzte mit sechzehn. So gross muss dieser Lutsche.
Ich glaube, ich hatte tatsächlich mal so einen Lutscher und ich hatte mal so einen riesigen Lutscher.
Und dann weiss man ja nicht, so soll man den von einer Seite anlecken oder von der anderen Seite oder rundrum oder was geht da, keine Anleitung. Ich war ein sehr, sehr vorsichtiges Kind, habe erst geguckt, ist eine Anleitung. Du hast eine Anleitung gesucht. Und dann habe ich irgendwann den geleckt und dann war tatsächlich, muss man sagen, selbst für mich irgendwann der Spaß vorbei und ich hatte keinen Bock mehr. Und dann habe ich den halt einfach verloren und irgendwann hatte ich ihn wieder gefunden und dann hatte ich den Hamburger Hafen rein und irgendwann nie wieder und dann und dann nämlich geht die story full circle also dann mit mit acht Cent der frau imponieren wolltest und sie ist dann diese Loni da und denkst genau ab heute stirbt meine Kindheit, ab heute bin ich ein Mann. Ich habe das erste mal eine Frau angelogen, ab jetzt bin ich ein Mann. Und dann ist Credits und das Publikum so, what, ist die Regel, man ist ein Mann, wenn man Frauen anlügt? What the fuck, alle Kinder im Publikum, hä? Und dann habe ich eines Tages diesen riesigen Lolli wiedergefunden und es war so ein Moment, wo ich dachte, ein alter Freund, ich habe ihn hochgenommen und er war komplett mit einer kompletten Schicht Ameisen bedeckt.
Komplett Ameisen, ja. Alles voller Ameisen. Und ich dachte mir so, hm, vielleicht mag ich ja Ameisen.
Und ich dachte mir auch in dem Moment, Alter, ein Ameisenbär wäre jetzt fucking, würde der einfach explodieren vor Freude.
Der war wirklich komplett mit Ameisen. Ich habe dann keine Ameisen gegessen, weil ich habe gehört, die sind giftig. Ich war ein sehr schlecht informiertes Kind. Ja, er kann dich anpinkeln und das beißt. Stimmt das denn? Das habe ich so einen Quatsch auch, oder? Ja, wir müssen auch mal diese Mythen aufräumen. Ich glaube, Ameisen pinkeln dich an oder beißen dich und das brennt. Hummeln können stechen. Muss man auch einmal sagen jetzt, dass viele Leute behaupten, Hummeln können stechen, Hummeln können stechen. Ja, dann dieses Elefanten haben Angst vor Mäusen, nein, haben sie nicht. Katzen haben Angst vor Burken, nein, haben sie nicht. Weiß ich nicht. Hunde sind männliche Katzen, nein, das nicht. Ich glaube, wir können heute alle was lernen. Füchse, F noch nichts drüber, wollen wir uns nicht aus dem Fenster lehnen. Noch gar nichts, Fuchs, Fragezeichen, ist es ein Hund, ist es eine hässliche Katze, wir wissen es leider nicht. Sind Sie wirklich schlau, was hat ein Fuchs gemacht, um dieses Schlau-Image zu bekommen eigentlich? Ich meine, die Essen aus Mülleimern, das kriege ich gerade auch noch hin. An einem schlechten Wochenende, wenn wir wieder die Läden zu haben. Okay, coole Idee, danke, baut das Gebäude hin und schliesst dann ab. Cool, coole Idee, alles was du willst ist da drin, aber die Tür ist zu, geil. Coole Idee, schlau, gut durchdacht. Ja, aber das ist eine gute Frage. Aber, kleiner Tipp, die Mülltonne hat keine Öffnungszeiten. Ladies. Ja, an alle Waschbären da draußen, ihr wisst, wovon ich rede. Noch nie hat jemand den Satz, Mülltonne haben keine Öffnungszeiten, so cool gesagt wie du gerade. Wir treffen uns nach der Show an der Mülltonne. Wer hat Lust? Aber ich glaube, du hast einen Punkt, weil der macht ja nichts Cleveres. Aber trotzdem hat er das Clever-Image. Vielleicht, weil er die Größe hat. Er ist ja genauso süss, arguably, wie Katzen und Hunde, ist ja auch irgendwo in der Mitte anzusetzen. Und ist aber genauso groß, hat sich aber nicht domestizieren lassen. Oh, das kann sein, dass der einfach gesagt hat, nee, ich lasse mich hier nicht züchten. Ich meine, wenn man das Image des Fuchses, wenn man jetzt mal in die geschichtliche Grundlage, wir machen jetzt wirklich wissenschaftliches Arbeiten, man geht zurück, Quellenprüfung, alles was wir mit dem Fuchs wissen, ist, er hat die Gans gestohlen. Und das ist Fakt, Fakt, Fakt. Und dann auch die Frage, Gänse, wie leicht lassen sich Gänse gestohlen? Genau, das finde ich auch geil, der hat sie gestohlen. Ist das das Seminar?
Okay.
Also Fuchs hat die Gans gestohlen, okay.
Genau, das ist was wir wissen über die Fuchs.
Und das Interessante an der Stelle, er hat die Gans gestohlen.
Schreiben Sie das auf.
Wölfe hingegen sind dumm.
Die kommen und fressen alles auf.
Wie schlau sind denn Gänse, um zu verstehen, wie groß die Leistung zu bewerten ist?
Gans ist so, sagen wir mal, so leicht unter so einer Amsel. Eine Gans ist so, ich meine, die Gans kann nicht fliegen, oder? Die hat eine Flügel, aber kann nicht fliegen, come on. Also Nils Holgersson ist auf Gänsen geflogen. Sorry, ich soll ja nicht reinreden, haben Sie mir schon. Das ist eine Quelle, die mir unbekannt ist. Nils Holgersson ging mit den Gänsen davon, ist nicht der Text. Ich glaube, ich muss meine gesamte Doktorarbeit. Fliegt mit den Gänsen davon. Naja, auf jeden Fall, der Fuchs klaut, stiehlt die Gans. Wolf, du hast die Gans gerissen, Fuchs, du hast die Gans gestohlen. Was passiert mit der Gans? Auf welchem Schwarzmarkt taucht die auf? Wo ist die Gans? Arbeitet vielleicht die Gans für die Fuchsfamilie? Ja, kann auch sein. Vielleicht wollte der Fuchs die Gans befreien, wir wissen es nicht. Deswegen sind die wahrscheinlich so schlau, weil wir einfach nicht verstehen, was da los ist. Und sie haben Bandwürmer, das habe ich auch als Kind. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das als Kind heutzutage noch lernt überhaupt. Bei mir war es immer so, Vorsicht vor dem Fuchs, denn die haben Bandwürmer und Tollwut. Und ich habe mein Leben nie einen Fuchs gesehen. Aber ich war immer bereit, jederzeit. Nein, stimmt nicht, ich habe einmal einen Fuchs getreten, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Wir haben einen Fuchs gesehen. Das ist ein Fuchs getreten. Das ist ein anderes Thema jetzt.
Das ist ein kälferen Fuchs getreten.
Nein, ich habe... Und er hat so gesagt, Entschuldigung, Sir.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nein, mich hat man tatsächlich mal beim Joggen Fuchs gebissen.
Das heißt, die sind auch sehr schnell, muss man sagen.
Mindestens so schnell wie ich.
Und ich kann schnell joggen.
Ich kann schnell joggen, ich bin ein Schnelljogger, weil ich Angst habe.
Wie schnell joggst du? Jog mal einmal so schnell wie du kannst?
Naja, also komm mal, das ist jetzt einfach...
Vielen Dank. und ich kann schnell joggen, ich kann schnell joggen, ich bin schnell jogger, weil ich Angst habe. Wie schnell joggst du? Jog mal einmal so schnell du kannst?
Naja, also komm, das ist jetzt einfach.
Da musst du bewerten.
Ja? So was, ja. Das ist noch ein anderes Tempo.
Und dann aber immer, aber tatsächlich, das Ding ist, bei meiner Jogtechnik, ich jogge nicht so schnell, aber mein Bremsweg ist extrem lang.
Also wenn man verfolgt, wie ich aufhöre zu joggen, ist es ein ... Und dann kommst du so nach Hause und dann musst du schon vorher anrufen, dass deine Frau die Tür aufmacht. Aber einfach lange. Dadurch kannst du nämlich immer Geschwindigkeit simulieren, indem dein Bremsweg einfach wahnsinnig lang ist. Aber auf welchem Teil dieser Story hat sich der Fuchs gebissen? Ungefähr hier. In dem Bereich kam der Fuchs. Ich bin durch sein Revier gerannt und er lief dann immer neben mir her tatsächlich. Ich bin immer nachts gerannt, weil ich nicht wollte, dass mich jemand sieht und dann lief der immer neben mir her, aber für so ein Stück, so für sein Revier und dann ist er wieder abgehauen und irgendwann hat er gesagt, Alter, jetzt reich, hau mal ab und danach hatte ich wahnsinnige Angst, weil ich hatte Angst, dass wenn ich den Fuchs nochmal sehe, ihn reflexhaft trete, nicht dass er mich nochmal beisst, niemand beisst mich zweimal, okay, niemand hat noch niemand geschafft, mich zweimal zu beissen, niemand, prüft das nach. Die Quellen sind sich einig. Ich hatte Angst, dass ich ihn trete, habe ihn nie wieder gesehen, also ist das nicht passiert. Aber ich hätte sterben können, am Bandwurm oder an Tollwut. Ich wurde jetzt gegen Tollwut geimpft. Oh! Sind drei Impfen tatsächlich. Gab es einen Anlass? Also haben die Füchse den Kreis um dich enger gezogen und gesagt hast du, ich muss jetzt handeln.
Ich muss handeln, ich weiß nicht, was ich tun soll dagegen.
Ne, weil wir jetzt bald, weil wir machen bald eine, wie viele Wochen, zwei Wochen machen wir Sommerpause. Och Gott, kleines bisschen.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Ihr müsst einmal raus.
Wir sind beide im Urlaub und da, wo ich hingehe, brauche ich Tollwutimpfung, weil ich gegen Bären kämpfe.
Du gehst...
Ich kämpfe gegen Schwarzbären in Kanada.
Ach so, ich dachte, du gehst nach Hannover. Kleiner Lokalkolorien-Gag. Ihr vertragt es doch, die Hannoveraner, die Hannoveraner, die können Gags umgehen. Die Hannoveraner, die Hannoveraner. Da sind die Hannoveraner unterwegs. Keine Ahnung, wie man Hannover spricht. Hochdeutsch. Hochdeutsch. Okay, ja, okay. Da kommt der Lokalstolz plötzlich um die Ecke. Moment mal, wo bist du im Urlaub? Peru. Peru. Sisi. Okay, wie kam es dazu? Ich besuche einen Freund, der auf Weltreise ist, stoss für eine Etappe dazu, habe sehr viel Angst, weil er dann auch meinte, du musst dich impfen lassen. Und das war jetzt eine kurzfristige Aktion. Und dann dachte ich mir, ja, aber die meisten Impfungen schaffe ich ja gar nicht mehr. Stimmt auch. Also sehr viele Impfen konnte ich nicht mehr bekommen, weil man die mehrmals bekommen muss. Und dann kam ich zum Arzt und dann hat er mich direkt, weil dann hat er mein altes Impfbuch gesehen. Ich habe es ein bisschen vernachlässigt, ehrlich gesagt. Man sollte regelmäßig hingehen. Und dann hat er mir direkt vier Impfen gegeben. Ich typhus tollwut also auch frischimpfung und hepatitis a und dann direkt so vier dinger rein und dann bin ich jetzt mal nach hause und habe mich hingelegt weil das war dein körper einfach so okay was ist hier los wo bist du da reingefallen ich bin dann nach Hause gegangen, wie du im Wald, und dann die Tür auf und dann pff, einfach. Einfach das Immunsystem so, Chef, übrigens wir haben Typhus, ne? Oh, okay. Oh, übrigens eins noch, wir haben Blindschleich, was weiß andere, keine Ahnung, wir haben Malaria übrigens auch noch. Okay, Joe, guck uns schnell nach im Buch, was wir gegen Typhus machen. Oh, Chef, übrigens, wir haben, keine Ahnung, wie die heißen ist, ich habe ein solches Schlechtesgedecktnis. Typhus, Typhus zwei, wir haben Typhus doppelt. Alles klar, alles klar. Wir haben vier verschiedene Grecken. Ja, einfach, lassen wir es. Was denkt sich dein Körper, ohne Scheiß. Ich würde so gerne ein Gespräch mit meinem Körper führen. Und der Körper so ... Aber auch lustig, dass du so abgekapselt bist, geistig von deinem Körper, dass du gerne ein Gespräch mit deinem Körper ... Viele sagen, aber ich kenne das, wenn Leute immer sagen, er hört auf deinen Körper, denke ich mir, er redet halt nicht mit mir. Ja, genau. Ist wie in der Kirche, er hört auf das Wort Gottes, ja, Boden! Und mein Körper redet auch nicht mit mir. Ich stell mir nur den Körper so vor wie so eine Firma mit so einer grossen Tür, wo immer reinkommt, was ich esse, so ein Stück Sahnetorte, okay, klar, Enzyme, ihr wisst, was zu tun ist, in Endoktrinen, klar, zack, rein damit, zack, oh, zweites Stück Sahnetorte, okay, alles klar, das wird ein harter Nachmittag, ihr wisst, was zu tun ist, produziert noch ein bisschen mehr Insulin und dann kriegen wir das dritte Stück, okay, wow, drittes Stück Sanetorte.
Bringt's rein, bringt's noch eine Kenwert. Okay, okay, kein Stress, kein Stress, ganz nach oben, Hungergefühl ausschalten, bitte. Alles klar, wir sind seit drei Stunden aus, wir sind seit drei Stunden aus. Wir haben nichts mehr auf Insulin, fünftes fucking Stück und so geht es einfach weiter, bis die Torte weg ist. Ah, endlich trinkt er was, endlich trinkt er was. Und wenn so Mr. Max die ganze Zentrale, die ganze Zentrale wird weggepftemmt. Und dann irgendwann sagt er, weisst du was, das lasse ich mir nicht gefallen, ich gehe jetzt hoch. Äh, Entschuldigung Chef, haben Sie ja eigentlich einen kompletten Schaden, können wir nicht die ganze Sahnetorte essen. Und dann so einen Scherzkeks wie du. Ja, und diesen Botschafter würde ich mir gerne wünschen. Er sagt so, die Mannschaft ist sehr unzufrieden gerade. Ja, einen ersten Mart. Wir wollen doch nur einen ersten Mart. Genau. Okay, warum denn? Naja, also sie sind in den Drive-In gefahren. Du zockst nicht am Konsole, ne? Ja, Entschuldigung. Die Mitarbeiter sind sehr unzufrieden, Chef, weil sie sind einmal in den Drive-In gefahren. Zuckt man doden sich. Du hast eine Maus und eine Tastatur, was glaubst du denn, was ich da mache? Ja, ich brauche auch ein Mikrofon in der Hand. Hast du ein Headset dabei auf? Nee, ich habe so ein Podcaster-Mikrofon und ein Kopfhörer auf. Ist die ganze Zeit kontinuierlich. Raik muss auf die Neun.
Ja, genau. Also klassische
Counter-Strike-Anweisungen und sowas
halt in der Richtung, ne? Machen wir jetzt mal nicht.
Für die Veranschaulichung.
Chef, übrigens, die Mannschaft ist sehr
unruhig gerade, weil sie sind in den
McDrive gefahren, haben
ein komplettes
McMenü und Chicken Nuggets
bestellt, sind dann rausgefahren und direkt nochmal in den Mac-Fall gefahren. Ja, mir fiel ein, dass ich noch zwei bis drei Mac-Floreys wollte. Ja, wir haben darüber gesprochen. Ich habe auf Pause gedrückt. Kann ich bei dem Spiel auf Pause drücken? Nein. Aber können Sie uns vielleicht mal kurz zuhören, weil wie gesagt, wir haben nichts mehr. Wir haben alles verbraucht und wir würden jetzt in den Streik gehen. Ich würde gerne noch eine Marze trinken. Ja, nee. Aber da ist auch Koffin drin. Ja. Was macht Koffin? Alles kaputt, alles kaputt. Alles noch viel, viel schlimmer. Okay. Noch viel schlimmer. Aber ich bin Florentin, ich trinke keinen Alkohol, ich n nehme keine Drogen, zumindest. Das ist gut, das ist super. Ja, oder nicht.
Lame, aber super.
Lame?
Ja, aber es ist... Mein Körper sagt lame.
Chef, können Sie vielleicht nochmal auf die Uhr gucken, es ist halb zwei.
Ich trage keine Armbanduhr.
Kein Koffein mehr, wenn es geht.
Danke, ist ja Körper, ich würde nochmal sagen.
Okay.
Jetzt Mr. Max, es ist nicht irgendwas. Das ist kein Scheiß, das ist Mr. Max. Das kostet weniger als Wasser. Warum hast du nicht überall Mr. Max eigentlich, weil in deine Schüsseln gemacht? Leg das weg. Weil du hättest überall auch einfach in deine Schüsselchen Mr. Max reinmachen. Weil es es nicht mehr gibt. Mr. Max ist ausverkauft. Das ist immer so dieses merkwürdige Phänomen, dass wenn ich was im Podcast Lob preise, dass es dann merkwürdigerweise verschwindet. Wer hat Mr. Max gekauft von euch? Niemand. Ja, ja, ja. Von daher, I don't know. Jetzt, wir treffen uns draußen und machen eine Kofferraumprobe. In jeden zweiten Kofferraum wird reingeschaut und ich konfisziere jede Flasche Mr. Max da draußen. Jedes Mal. Es ist einfach zu viel. Ich krieg's nirgendwo mehr. Ich krieg's wirklich nirgendwo mehr. Das ist doch gut für dich. Ich hab's immer gesehen. Ja, ich weiß, du siehst die letzte Chance für meine Gesundheit. Ja, aber ich... Weißt du, wie lange ich dafür gebraucht habe, diese ganzen Läden aufzukaufen? Ja, weil es nicht kennt, Mr. Max sind fünf Liter ein Euro, easy. Mehr müsst ihr gar nicht wissen, es sind fünf Liter ein Euro. Es ist eine Limo ohne Kohlensäure, fünf Liter ein Euro. Es sind fünf Liter ein Euro, easy. Also es ist, mehr müsst ihr gar nicht wissen, es sind fünf Liter ein Euro. Es ist eine Limo ohne Kohlensäure fünf Liter ein Euro. Es sind fünf Liter für ein Euro. Für zwei Euro zehn Liter. Fünf Euro fünfundzwanzig Liter. Das sind drei Tage. Das ist einfach, das ist unfassbar. Das ist einfach großartig. Hannover, es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Leute, wir sehen euch gleich draußen, ich will jeden einzelnen von euch vorbeifahren sehen, wir machen einen Kofferraumtest. Ansonsten vielen, vielen Dank, dass Sie da waren, Hannover. Hau rein, danke schön, wir wünschen uns wieder voll. Applaus für unseren kleinstjüngsten Zuhörer. Vielen Dank! Ciao!